george let me ask you two things so
for you um
you know you look at somebody who uh
competes at the high level we typically
hear some stuff that people say oh that
guy's just so confident oh that guy's
got no fear or that guy's got the reason
why he's doing this so he trains so hard
because he just wants to beat everybody
so bad and then deep down inside when
you go find out actually why this guy
trained so hard is because this person
is driven by
doesn't want to get humiliated publicly
so this person's like there's no way i'm
going to lose publicly everybody's going
to watch me
i train extra cuz i'm not going to be
publicly humiliated it's just not going
to happen to me right uh and some you
know
you said something about the fact that
you always go into a fight you got this
weird feeling you're afraid you oh my
god what if this goes wrong but if that
goes around the only fight you ever
didn't feel this way was sarah when
you're like you when i was like i was
good i'm like i'm not gonna lose to this
guy and that's the one you lost because
you didn't go on paranoid right that
dynamic yeah what did you ever have a
moment in your career
that you
not necessarily fear but in a moment
where you were fighting
something happened to the body or either
on the fear end or humiliation end where
you said
[ __ ] i i don't what am i like what was
this all about that
either brought in the best of you or the
worst of you humiliation as well as fear
i never liked
to fight i never liked it people like oh
you're bullshitting no man i never liked
it
i love
the freedom the freedom that it brings
me
i love the fact that it keeps me in
shape
i love the confidence that this sport
gives me i love to go to the gym to
train with my training partner the
camaraderie that i have
i love the science of the game the the
art of war the the the chess game of
fighting
i love that i love that that i have
access of things that most people do not
have access i love that
but in order to preserve that i needed
to go take that walk and fight in the
octagon in it but i hated it i despised
it i never liked it i never enjoyed it a
second never liked it i like to win
but the worst part for me
the worst day of the year for me is the
days that i'm fighting it's terrible
it's unbearable
and
when i was young
i remember when i started my career
because i wanted to be champion but i
needed to go through that pain to that
grind in order to achieve what i when i
wanted to achieve my goal
and i was looking around to all my
training partners and a lot of them
it seems to me that i was making fun i
was like you guys are like psychopath
because there it's either they were
acting or telling me they're true
but
i i felt i was not in the right field of
work because they were they were telling
me oh i'm happy to do this i can't wait
to fight and i'm like you guys are crazy
man me i'm scared like i can't wait that
it's over but i don't like the process
and i i tried to
to seek the help of sport psychologists
at the time because i was like maybe i'm
not in in the right lane
and the sport psychologist used to tell
me george try to brainwash me he goes
george
stop saying you're afraid you're you're
excited and i was like
it does not apply here you know because
you're excited when you're in montreal
and it's minus 20 degree and
you know that next week you're going in
vacation and the beach i will be excited
or you know what i mean i will be
excited if i'm fasting for three days
and
i'm about to eat my favorite dish i'm
excited i can't wait but i'm not
excited to go fight in a cage not
knowing if i will be badly hurt or
humiliated i'm afraid and then i start
realizing i said you know what
there is no courage without fear i
should not be afraid to admit that i'm
afraid wow and i realize also that that
fear that i had
makes me
way more
way more dangerous
because i realize that it it enhanced my
power my reaction time my decision
making making time that fair gives me
the drive to train harder in the fear
that my opponent train even harder than
me
helps me prepare even better in the fear
that my opponent is is getting is doing
more than me so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]
you